how you doing buddy I'm good how are you
good man what can I do for you tonight
so I'm a Marine in the U.S and uh just
like the past six months have kind of
really been into the whole red pill
learning about the country learning how
corrupt everything is and learning how
messed up the system is and uh it's come
to like give me a lot of doubts okay and
uh a lot of people especially in the
military are we're gearing up for a war
against China potentially
uh or if not a war in the in the Pacific
sometime and it could happen at any time
you know just like any War No One Ever
Knows when it's gonna happen yeah and uh
if it did I wasn't I'm not sure if I
would be uh comfortable especially if
we're going to war defending Taiwan for
some microchips against people like
like I don't know they're probably going
to go in your car to shut it off exactly
so I I don't know if I would be uh I
have a duty to myself to my boys and
that's the biggest thing is like
uh my my job and my role in my unit is
pretty big and uh I have a duty to my
boys but at the same time I don't want
to die for microchips
and uh I want to know what you thought
about that and I'm also like I do want a
challenge like the reason I joined is
because I want to prove like I want to
do some something that like makes me a
man you know and proves that I I'm a
more than just average how old are you
so uh 19 you sound stronger and more
virtuous than most of the guys that I
get calls from so
um that's that's the upside of the
military is it is it does make men out
of boys very quickly
um you know the downside is of course
you can be forced into proxy awards that
you may not necessarily agree with in
fact most most vets that I know
um don't like War they don't like the
idea of it they think they waste the
time they've seen friends die that
shouldn't have died over something that
was irrelevant
um and like you're just fodder you know
men are just disposable we've always
been disposable fortunately the you know
the good news is if you look at a
timeline throughout history and I'm not
talking about like the last hundred
years but I'm talking about like the
last hundreds of thousands of years
where Wars have been documented we live
in the most peaceful time in history
right we just don't War as often as we
have in the past like there was Wars
happening literally all the time
everywhere throughout history this is
this is a very peaceful time
so to your question is like what do I
think of that like what do I think of it
in what sense like what do you asking me
more specifically if we were to go to
war and I had the choice of of going or
uh or saying no I don't want to do this
and getting you know I would obviously
be shamed by everyone I know besides my
family and of course those close to me
which is all all that really matters to
me but uh I'm wondering what would you
do in that situation
you know it's interesting because
I wanted to sign up for the Royal Air
Force when I was a kid when I was 18. I
wanted Florida the Harrier jump Jets uh
Falkland war was kind of happening just
around that time a few years earlier
actually but um
yeah I just I just don't endorse it
today you know it's the same thing like
you know with policing like I don't
endorse men getting into policing they
hate you you're always racist you can't
do anything right you know if you move
the wrong way if you touch your gun then
you got to write you know three days
worth of reports
um there's a lot of
you know conventionally masculine roles
that that men have filled you know like
over the last several decades that I've
watched that have deteriorated to the
point where I don't think that I'd want
to participate in that so that's a
choice that you got to make for yourself
I mean if I was 19
maybe you took what you need from it and
you know you formed the fresh you're the
friend the friendships and the
brotherhoods but if they said to me oh
we're gonna go and pick a fight with
China for me personally I'd be like have
fun go I'm not interested I don't want
to fight your stupid War I don't care
right but that's just how you like like
I'm more of a Libertarian I don't want
to get involved in other people's
problems like what happens on the other
side of the world doesn't affect me but
there's people that argue oh it does
affect you because if you don't stop it
over there then it's going to come over
here
I I think our bigger problems are more
domestic
it's not what China's doing to Taiwan or
whatever like I've watched a lot of
documentaries on the conflict between
Taiwan and China and you know the
differences they have and realistically
if China is going to take Taiwan they
have to do it in the next four years
exactly they can't wait 10 or 20 years
like they won't have the industry they
want to have the people they won't have
the means to wage that war and win it
they would have to do it in the next
four years so if they're smart and
they're going to do it it's coming soon
but is it worth it to them I don't know
I don't know like I don't know what
their policies are I don't live there I
don't think you know the way they did
but you know the thing that you got to
remember you know I was watching this
other video
their leader Xi Jinping I'm pronouncing
you know completely wrong you gotta
remember this was a guy that grew up in
a remote village where people starved
under the old version of Chinese
communism and if you're going to try to
tell an old man that grew up an
environment like that what to do you're
like he's he doesn't care about the you
know the states doesn't care about their
ability to wage war he doesn't care
about how many aircraft guys like that
just don't care right so if they want
something they're gonna go and take it
and it's going to be messy I don't know
that I'd want to
it's it's just going to be messy it's
not something that I won't want to be a
part of right yeah the first the first
people were there I mean I'm I'm in the
Infantry I'm in the front lines I I know
the first people who are going to be
there are going to be quite literally
cannon fodder there's gonna be drone
strikes like you won't make it to the
beach there won't be at Normandy Beach
no nowadays basically technically Taiwan
is China's property like if you look at
the you know historical records in the
way that they related to Taiwan Taiwan
is China
right so right I don't know it's you
know it's going to unfold the way that
it's going to unfold what am I going to
do what are you going to do to change
that you know do you want to put
yourself in an environment where there's
there's a fairly decent probability that
you're probably going to die right over
some something that you don't really
care about because some guy over there
and some glass you know some Ivory
Towers said that we have to go do that
because if we can't let them get away
with that that's just wrong
that's just me though right the biggest
part for me is just my manly Hood at
like it would be like having to that's
where they'll get a watchful exactly I
know but that's part of the psyop that
they drill into your head yeah when you
join yeah so I'm trying to trying to
escape that right now but I very much
appreciate talking to you this is very
good for me you got it man you have a
good night I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out